continúan las protestas en Perú las vías
a lo largo del país permanecen
bloqueadas mientras que en la capital
Lima las protestas terminaron nuevamente
en enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
la fuerza pública yo sus propias leyes a
sus beneficios cumpliendo fielmente esa
Constitución cochina del 93 en ello
están regidos ellos lejos de escuchar
nuestra voz los gobernantes han mandado
a aniquilar a nuestros hermanos a
masacrar a nuestros pueblos entonces
hemos tenido que mandar a nuestros
hermanos a nuestros esposos a nuestros
hijos a la capital para que sean
escuchados
esos enfrentamientos marcan la peor
violencia que Perú ha visto en más de 20
años y que afecta a 18 de los 24
departamentos del país las autoridades
de la capital estiman que sufrieron
pérdidas materiales por al menos 210 mil
dólares durante la denominada toma de
Lima el 19 de enero que dejó imágenes
como estas las manifestaciones llevan
casi dos meses y por ahora el gobierno
de Dina boluarte se aferra al poder
asegurando que realizará investigaciones
para determinar las más de 50 muertes
que han dejado las protestas Mientras
tanto en cusco al menos 300 turistas se
encuentran varados por las protestas
luego de que manifestantes bloquearan el
tren que conduce a Machu Picchu eso
sería todo ahorita estamos pues con
incertidumbre saber si va a venir va a
venir algún tren a recogernos como verán
todos los turistas aquí estamos haciendo
una cola para Pues están recolectando
firma y están empadronando
entre tanto los manifestantes han
asegurado que mantendrán las protestas
hasta que vean cambios aumentando la
inestabilidad en un país que ha tenido
seis presidentes en los últimos seis
años